la base de cognac est chargée de former
les pilotes sous-officier de l'armée de
l'air
c'est là sa mission principale mais bien
sûr comme toutes les bases d'une
certaine importance ils ont également à
former les jeunes recrues qui nous
arrive
et quelles formations suivies style et
bien ces jeunes recrues auront d'abord
une instruction théorique d'une durée de
deux à trois mois et ensuite nous les
mettons dans les unités nous nous
efforçons de les faire travailler de
leur métier et vous accueillez
aujourd'hui des jeunes recrues
exactement et si vous voulez nous
pouvons aller voir comment se passe la
corporation
ils arrivent le matin soit par la route
soit par le train était qu'il se
présente au poste de police
ils sont recueillis par un sous-officier
qui en prend 1,10 par disent qu'il est
prend 10 par dix
et qui constitue la cellule dans
laquelle ils vont vivre pendant leur
classe c'est-à-dire deux mois
alors leur instruction commence au bout
de 24 à 48 heures lorsqu'ils ont fini
leur incorporation c'est à dire
lorsqu'ils sont habillés et que
personnellement je leur ai souhaité la
bienvenue au point de vue des loisirs
compte ils à leur disposition et bien
sûr la base nous avons quand même pas
mal de choses d'abord un cinéma avec une
séance journalière gratuite
le foyer que vous avez devant vous il
trouve distraction barre pour s'amuser
et enfin les clubs clubs de disques clog
folklorique aéromodélisme et nous avons
également une section de vol à voile
pour ce que les choses de l'air temps
particulièrement
donc je
d'où venez vous je viens d avec d autres
du village qui se trouve aux environs de
coutras de revel à côté d'un septième et
d'angoulême de saint brieuc château du
joueur de brive la gaillarde et que
faites vous dans l'axé lille je le
travaille en stop paris étudiants je
suis électricien étudiant en droit
je suis mécanicien entretien
joué-lès-tours chez michelin je suis
comptable j'ai terminé mes études
quelle est votre première impression
mais auparavant je suis tombé sur une
bonne base
j'espère que mon impression va se
prolonger pour l'instant elles sont
assez bonnes
la première impression c'est toujours un
peu timide sur un drap sur une base
comme ça alors c'est un peu le cafard
mais c'est pas ça bouge pas mal joué je
crois que c'est assez accueillant enfin
restons bravant la suite l'aviation vous
intéresse non pas du tout je prenne
beaucoup plus l'aviation et les cheveux
en sais rien pas grave si on peut leur
faire de mal j'ai l'impression
en effe au z varicelle pas de rubéole
scarlatine choisir votre carnet que vous
avez une coqueluche phoenix également
vous n'avez jamais été ma femme du
gardien qui jusqu'à maintenant je
connais donc le ballon tu sais que tu
pourras profiter de son séjour à l'armée
pour te faire soigner et éventuellement
te faire faire des prothèses au centre
aux régionales si tu as coefficient
masticatoire est suffisant je serais tu
alors là c'est une chambre exactement
vous avez la chambre type pour les
jeunes recrues avec les dix lits et
l'armoire individuel
c'est ici que nous assistons à la
véritable transformation du civil en
militaires alors tout d'abord les
mensurations puis ensuite un certain
nombre de renseignements qui servent à
l'été pour déterminer l'état civil la
personne à prévenir en cas d'accident
les sports pratiqués et bien d'autres
enseignements dont on a besoin plutôt
cours de son service militaire
à
on
à quoi sert cet instrument très précieux
dans un magasin d'habillement
je vais vous montrer tout de suite mais
à vous voyez vous êtes un mauvais
militaire vous n'êtes pas en tenue
réglementaire le manteau est trop
longtemps normalement vous devez lui
situé entre les deux corps
bon
alors là le visiteur se rhabiller
exactement nous venons de finir la
chaîne d'habillement
c'est maintenant un militaire à part
entière